[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 어 제가
약간 브이로그처럼 어 촬영을 켰는데
오늘 제
생일입니다네
그래서 침에 와이프가 해준 그
미역국을 먹고 출근을
하는데 좀 되게 기분이 좋은 거
같아요 아침부터 미역국도 해 줄 수
있는 사람도 있고 어 정말 좀 행복한
삶을 살고 있지 않나 이렇게 생각을
합니다 아
오늘은 웬만하면 일정은 좀 다 뺐어요
그래서 집에 좀 일찍 들어가서
가족들이랑 좀 생일을 보낼 예정입니다
오늘 좀 이렇게 생일 일정이 좀
어떻게 되는지 어
생일에 뭔가 있었던 일들을 좀 이렇게
영상으로 담아보도록 하겠습니다
회사에서 뵙도록
하겠습니다네 회사에 도착했습니다
회사 도착하자마자 저희 직원분들이
준비를 굉장히 좀 많이 해주셨어요
그래서 어 제가 오늘은 전 원한테
커피를 좀 사야 될 거 같습니다
그래서 정말 너무 감사하고 제가 더
좀 잘 보답하고 더 열심히
해야겠다라는 그런 생각을 좀 하게
됐습니다 어 그리고 제가 출근하자마자
요즘에는 책을 한시간 정도 씁니다
빌딩 관련된 책이고 어 신축이나
리모델링 제가 이제 직접했던 것들
위주로 좀 이렇게 책을 쓰고 있는데
아마 가을에 좀 출간될 예정인데
여러분들 정말 기대하셔도 좋을 만한
그런 책입니다 그다음에 최근에 모
기업에 동기부여 강의 제안이 와서
강의 안도 좀 준비하고 있어요 좀 잘
준비해서 그 회사 직원들한테 좀 이제
조금이라도 도움이 될 만한 그런
내용들을 좀 준비하려고 합니다 오늘
아침부터 좀 기분이 되게 좋아요 뭐
있을 때마다 계속해서 영상을 좀
찍도록 하겠습니다 그 이따
뵙겠습니다
우셨다
셨다
들어가요 지금 지금
지금
로 뭐야
이뭐야 뭐야 뭐야 생이
[음악]
축하합니다
축하합니다 사랑을
님
[음악]
[박수]
축하합니다 아
어네
소이라 무 아 감사합니다 준비 많이
해주시고
축하드립니다 아데 저 켜놓은 거 좀
소리 좀
줄여야지 아 대표님 생일 축하드립니다
늘 항상 진치 이이고 도전하는
모습에서 항상 귀감이 되십니다 늘
항상 감사드리고 어 행복과 건강이
더할 나이 없기를 바라겠습니다 생일
축하드립니다 장님 생이 진심으로
축하드립니다 저희 올해 2024년
팬트 팀 열심히 할테니까 기대 많이
해 주시고요 항상 저희 뒤에서 든든한
버팀목이 되어 주셔서 정말 감사합니다
사장님 생일 진심으로
축하드립니다니다 대표님은 참 배울
점이 많으신 분인데요 제가 이제 4년
차 사남면 이제 일을 하고 있는데
제가 신입사 때 제가 무조건 1등으로
와야겠다 하고 출근을 하면 항상
계시더라고요 그래서 그 좀
솔선수범하고 좀 출퇴근이나 모든
면에서 이제 타 모범이 되는 그런
면을 좀 배우고 싶습니다 김민수
대표님은 저에게 기둥 같은
존재이십니다 항상 사함을 위해 힘써
주셔서 감사드립니다 김민수 대표님의
장점은 항성 긍정적이고 신중하신 편인
거 같습니다 사장님 벌써 2024년
2월이네요 사장님 생생 축하드리고 어
올해 목표 모두 이루시기 바랍니다
파이팅 김 대표님
축하드립니다 경하는 사장님의 생일을
진심으로 축하드립니다
축 시작 생일
축하합니다니다 생일
축하합니다 사랑하는
사장님 생일
축하합니다